so you have Dan santis go out there he's
bashing Trump trump should be here on
the stage you know basically just
insulted that Trump isn't there to take
him seriously and blame Republicans for
the inflation blame Republicans for
inflation blamed Trump for inflation
said that Trump adding 7.8 trillion
dollar to the national debt while he was
in office is what leads to inflation now
well you know when Trump left office
inflation was at
1.44% by December 2022 it was I think at
6.5 right now it's at like 3 67 so Biden
is saying oh it's better than it was but
it's only better than it was after he
jacked it up ridiculously and it's still
twice as high as it was when Trump was
in office and the national debt like
adding if you scroll down you could see
the numbers of the national debt like
there's large numbers uh Trump brought
the national debt up to like 32 trillion
something up from 32 trillion something
now it's over 33 trillion